We think it's incredibly important that
you get feedback on your code as you
write it, so we created the Udacity
Front End Feedback Chrome extension
to give you feedback on quizzes
as you work on your own computer.
To set it up, visit the Chrome
web store and search for
the Udacity feedback extension.
There is also a link to it below.
Once you've found it,
download the extension to add
it to your Chrome browser.
Next, you'll want to edit
the settings for the extension
by right clicking the extension icon and
selecting manage extensions.
Make sure the extension is enabled and
that you've checked the setting
to allow access to file URLs.
If you don't select this option then
you won't be able to immediately use
the extension locally.
Once you've configured the extension,
simply open up a quiz
that uses the extension.
If you don't see tests loaded in the top
right hand corner of your browser,
click the extension icon and
select allow feedback on this domain.
If the tests don't pop up after that,
then try refreshing the quiz.
And that's it.
If you followed these steps, then
you're now ready to get started with
the Udacity Front End
Feedback Chrome extension.
Good luck.